you posted photos of your dog fuzz here
this is this is him drinks what I would
call asta stress was because I didn't
know I well I always had big dogs
growing up but now I have a small dog
and it turns out small dogs they they
you have to like milk their anal glands
and so tell me more wait a minute I have
heard about this I had a dog I usually
have bigger dogs is this true you have
to get in there now who does this well
people tell me I should do it myself but
I take him to the vet but it's become
like this major part of my life where
I'm constantly monitoring like does my
dog's ass need milking soon yes it does
okay I need to get to the milk er yeah I
[Applause]
have two little dogs and you take him to
the groomer and they extract their anal
glands yes I would never do it myself
though well right because it involves
like fingers and things like know what a
professional do it yeah my future
father-in-law told me I should be doing
it myself just getting the dog in a
little headlock and kind of giving him a
milk you know
over the years and it's been a lot of
years on this show people have sort of
mind a lot of different actions what you
just did right there was one of the
weirder and creepier things I've seen
anybody do be a lady well this is really
good you're doing a lot of good by
getting out here and telling people
about milking your dog's anal glands you
must you should do it a PSA for this hi
I'm a tea Brian you know it would be my
honor yeah
you just said it was an honor to be on
this show
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you